New research shows that by looking at a person’s
face, you can tell what they do for a living.
Be honest - you always knew I was a GQ model.
Hey people who have faces, this is DNews and
I am Trace face.
We're taught not to judge a book by its cover,
but when you look at a face, you make an assessment
about its owner’s personality, character,
and inner qualities.
This process is called physiognomy from a
Greek word meaning "the art of judging someone’s
character from their appearance."
Everybody does it.
Our brains take cognitive shortcuts all the
time, using past (or assumed) knowledge to
make determinations in the present.
And according to a new study, we're pretty
good at guessing correctly.
The study, published in Leadership Quarterly,
found that a person’s job could be accurately
identified just by looking at their face.
Out of 325 CEOs, 64 US Army Generals, 66 state
governors, and 43 American football coaches
-- all unknowns -- the participants were able
to accurately match face to occupations at
a better rate than pure "chance.”
A study in Science Magazine found that when
Swiss children as young as five years old
were shown pictures of French leaders running
for Parliament, they could predict who would
win the election with scary accuracy.
Another study found in only 100 milliseconds,
people could judge and predict, in advance,
the winners of around 70 percent of U.S. gubernatorial
and Senate races, with no prior knowledge
of the candidates!
In fact, studies show we'll judge faces first
based on sex or gender, age, and ethnicity.
After that, we'll take into account facial
symmetry, height-to-width ratio, and "baby-faceness."
From that we can pretty accurately judge a
number of traits: mainly trustworthiness and
dominance.
From these we determine attractiveness, responsibility,
aggressiveness and threat, and even intelligence
and morality!
A 2016 study in Cogent Psychology found older
voters tend to look for older, more attractive
faces, while younger voters were less influenced
by attractiveness.
The implication here is that if we judging
faces implicitly, we're doing the same in
the voting booth.
Essentially, scientists are saying we may
not be voting based on any policy or job-related
information, but just these implicit judgements.
In fact, there's a whole area of the brain
dedicated to facial recog within the temporal
lobe called the fusiform gyrus.
When we determine something is a face, then
ostensibly, the fusiform gyrus will process
that face while higher brain areas make a
judgement about it.
The Cognitive Miser theory says whenever it
can, our brain will take the shortcut of using
an easy-to-evaluate characteristic instead
of taking the time to make a more accurate,
but time consuming judgement.
And back to that first Leadership Quarterly
study?
They found we're actually really bad at knowing
this is happening.
We do it subconsciously...
Which is pretty scary to think about.
So when you're looking at your candidates
this year, maybe stop looking at them and
listen to what they say, read their platforms,
and talk with others about their ideas.
Don’t forget, you’re literally deciding
the face
of
the future.